few days ago in the live chat for the on
my show someone wrote in this is Nick
Gawker goes by MK Ultra in the pr crem
member chat he said hey tell your
producer to check the mailbag I just
sent in a rap song about Mayflower
cigars and I said okay that's kind of
funny and we'll see what it what it is I
was floored this man sent in what I
consider to be the music video of the
year I know a lot of us are talking
about rap these days St St St this maybe
I think it's the top take it
away it's music Monday
[Music]
baby it's a nice looking
Lounge da stick lit up my chest inhale
just a little but not to excess goes
best with a glass a whiskey your Brandy
enjoy like one up after dinner with the
family made flowers cigars got them
speechless from subtle undertones and
not to sweetness some call him noas a
big papa Sicilian known for BS a big
pasta crucifix hang on the wall pray off
father car smoke cigar
from the we so put your name up on the
soon as it comes in he send you another
Boxer the finest cigars that always come
and Roll pop but can't stop the dust
from burning
[Music]
that's cuz made in the image of God's
likeness so sit down have another pint
with a quanus no smoke out of my nose
got the lips saying that I'm blowing hes
in the ozone burn the Effigy but he
still didn't postpone Smokey might keep
on rolling he going so local it's insane
my soft flame illuminate the picture
frame written books with no ink in one
page Smoke Clears and I'm living in the
end of day days tell producer day throw
me on a Monday we in a circle like it's
be and Dante stepping in we casting
demons out like Benedict so
get and the
in we in a circle like beatric and Dante
this
is phenomenal this is the greatest rap
song I've ever heard in my life the
production quality is outrageous some
Callum Nostradamus or big pop Cil known
for bowls of big pasta damn son yeah put
your hands in the air if you a true
player of the finest cigars that always
come and roll proper so that that's a
clear illusion to the notorious VI right
listen I'm not a I'm not saying I'm A
hip-hop Maven or whatever but that's
that is brilliant writing a lovely and
it's a call back to you know big papa
and the big pasta stoies roll like
ancient Scrolls of Papyrus throw my
light loafers on I'm feeling stylish wa
man damn
son the best line the best line by far
crem do creme women and men we the
flyest that's cuz we made in the image
of God's likeness so sit down have
another pint with ainus blow smoke out
of my nose got the libs saying I'm
blowing holes in the
ozone whoo okay I take it I take it back
what I said
earlier the best line in the song is we
in a Circle it's like beatric and Dante
stepping in we casting demons out like
Benedict so get your medicine and never
let the devil in whoa it's
good I'm blown away it was all a dream I
used to read Word Up Magazine salt and
pepper and heavy tea up in the
lousine